[Applaus]
rein damit so das ist das erste treibt
ist dann müssen wir die maschine kann
man schon gesehen ein mal rein
ok so haben wir einmal drehen jetzt fest
ok habe ich mich dann alles klar
man kommt das ipad drauf und der sommer
zurück
der ist die forschung ist ja nicht
einfach
jetzt müssen wir das anschließend das
sagt das wasser rein und die chemie
später das ist das klare wasser nach zum
beispiel einmal so ziehen das ist clips
versionen auch anschließen
die einmal also schmutzige wasser später
zu neutralisieren kommt dann hier rein
so hier ist mir das auch machen da kommt
das klare wasser rein so dann kommt
jetzt hier was dabei
jetzt haben wir der beschleuniger auch
hier kommen wir zu mir wenn das ist
typisch für den vor dem fleck hier nicht
zu viel
das war's jetzt
immer kreise bewegung machen das doch
jeder vor
mit chemie fühlst dann wenn man hier
ende fertig ist die wahl ein bisschen
runter den krieg sieht
sie laufen länger aufbleiben auf den
flächen
[Musik]
so jetzt mehr ein flecken mehr kann man
die einstellungen auch sei zu tun
jetzt sind wir mit dem ersten
arbeitsvertrag fertig stellen wir die ab
es kommt das nächste gerät also hiermit
sagen jetzt dass die chemikalien weg
also es kommt vor dass klare wasser und
dann sagt man beides ab sozusagen das
tier muss man gleich drauf drücken kann
auch so und dann wird das dann alles
sauber sagt ich mache das jetzt
[Musik]